alors les scieries je vais vous raconter
aujourd'hui l'histoire des grandes
cérémonies à la télé alors c'est en 76
en france que la toute première édition
des césar du cinéma et crée même si
aujourd'hui des audiences ne sont pas au
top
à l'époque quand jean gabin ouvre la
toute première cérémonie
ces gens gagnent en qui on garde toute
première cérémonie et oui c'est un
immense acteur un jean gabin c'est comme
vous dites aujourd'hui le forcené
le public est pendu à ses lèvres et elle
était présentée par un immense acteur
jean claude brialy
regardez non seulement c'est notre plus
grand acteur français mais je peux vous
dire
et pour qu'ils montent démarche c'est
quelque chose alors la trace bon ben
alors je dis la phrase ce soir pour la
première année on va remettre les
récompenses du cinéma français des
césars comme il se doit
je déclare la cérémonie ouverte voilà
franchement est-ce et la glace et jean
capin alors je vous le dis alors qu'il
ya plus de deux chaînes qui pèse pas
monsieur qui n'est pas connu
voilà jean gabin mine de rien je crois
qu'il était décédé voilà quand je lis
aussi oui mais jean gabin non mais c'est
vrai et voilà que je suis comme un
chercheur associé au cinéma ou à la
france
mais croyez-moi c'est là que c'est la
classe c la com alors on 71 surtout que
là c'est en 76 en images
donc c'était cinq ans après sa mort les
autres le parfum l'autre qui dit des
conneries mais avec un applaudissement
des ouais là l'image quand même parce
qu'en 76 donc c'était fabuleux après sa
mort merci
mais cela tort il explique jean gabin il
a fait lui il a fait la cérémonie
d'ouverture des scénars cinq ans après
sa mort pour de lambris d'arrivée on
l'appelait espèrons la paix' prêt à
aller dans l'histoire des césar il ya
quelques bons mots culte en dix ans en
1981 louis de funès reçoit un césar
d'honneur
il avait d'abord refusé louis de funès
refusé puis acceptée à une seule
condition que ce soit un acteur
américain qui s'appelle jerry lewis qui
lui remettent
c'était la seule condition est bien sûr
l'acteur américain a tout de suite
accepté
regardez c'était trois ans avant la
disparition de but de funès donc là sous
des lois de finances oui il était encore
vivant quand il était donc voilà un
chantier énorme tient sur la latte donc
la cote il est venu chercher son césar
d'honneur était encore vivant regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo ah oui c'était un grand moment
regardez qu'est ce que vous avez dans
qu'est ce que vous avez castaldi
castaldi vous êtes un forcené lâcher ça
castagne on ne vous entend pas castaldi
vous êtes un forcené lâcher sa jeune et
je lève et je n'ai moi moi je l'est avec
moi nous avons mal commencé pour dix à
vingt six a commencé vie que vous n'avez
pas à oui pour la vie devant soi
moshe mizrahi excusez moi c est lâché ça
lâche et ç'a le forcené alors danse les
césar
ce qu'on aime aux césars aussi c'est les
gaffes la plus grosse bourde elle est
est fait en 1991 la plus grosse bourde
aux césar est ce que vous savez par qui
qui a fait la plus grosse de l'année
sans tabac lundi
vanessa paradis bravo et vanessa paradis
elle annonce la mauvaise gagnante sache
que vous dire vous attendez toute la
soirée
attendez votre nom et après on vous dit
que c'est pas vous ça c'est dur regarde
tes lecteurs connaissent un paradis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
1990 meilleur espoir féminin pour notre
planche côté chanson un album signé
servir
[Applaudissements]
j'ai encore plus jaune
je vous jure je vais pas laisser that
attribué à gidy que dresse temps je suis
désolé excusez moi si j'ai dit on et
henry dans la discrétion
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est du rsa c'est très très dur ya
richard de ranger à côté et judith
godrèche la pause toute sa vie elle doit
s'en souvenir judy wade et ouais et la
vanessa paradis bien sûr était là et
elle est toujours avec nous un matthieu
delormeau monsieur jean gabin aînés le
temps ce sont celles-là je le dis
malheureusement autre moment culte c'est
un grand moment d'émotion dans les césar
est-ce que vous rappelez en 96 annie
girardot
je crois que c'est un beau moment des
faits on est vécue dans les césar elle
reçoit l'as tu es tu pour le meilleur
second rôle féminin
elle est mal en point à ce moment là et
c'est vrai que c'est une immense actrice
regarder si vous ne connaissez pas ni
girardot là tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent les moins jeunes regardez ça
c'était un moment qu'on manipule ceux
des cérémonies baraquements et regarder
ça je sais pas si j'ai manqué au cinéma
français mais à moi le cinéma français a
manqué follement éperdument
douloureusement
votre témoignage votre amour me font
penser que peut-être je le dis bien
peut-être ceci pas encore tout à fait
morte
voilà alors ça ça c'était un grand
roanne gérardo qui était une immense
actrice annie gioux ça c'est des grands
moments dans les césar et puis forcément
dans les césar il ya eu énormément de
moments drôles le je pense que le plus
gros délire qu'on ait vu c'était à jamel
debbouze jamel qui fait un énorme bisou
moshiri il est avec adriana karembeu 199
je ne me lasse pas de cette image et ça
il venait remettre un césar ensemble et
là franchement on se dit c'est vrai que
ça a pris un coup les césar quand on
voit ça regardez
si tu pilotes juste je sais je suis pas
juste comme je croyais en approche avec
eric cantona ici sans bruit et patrice
carmouze dans les dents les bains non
pourquoi va le faire tout seul c'est pas
bien ça pour quoi
tu vas me dire la soirée pas s'ennuyer
petit c'est non
enfin vous vous avez pas le parti de sel
quand même je vais pas te manger la
culotte façon vous savez comment te dire
je parle un peu vos yeux sont aussi
rapides que disait dans la collision
d'un oiseau
vos cheveux je me sens aussi espiègle
qu'elle échoue mais à trois ans oui
jamel jamel vous plaît s'il vous plaît
djamel as possible j'appelle à l'ol
vas-y elle ne parle pas très bien
français j'ai bien compris quand brabham
d'ici là est la différence
ebadi fiq la différence de taille web
mobile c'est prodigieux franchement
djamel mais il a un sens du rythme de 2
de l'impro du truc c'est un spectacle à
lui tout seul et aujourd'hui on voit
plus ça aujourd'hui c'est plus aseptisée
iard pas ça voilà pourquoi j'emmerde
tout jamais je vais vous dire il a non
seulement il est bon ou un pro mais
c'est un énorme bosseur diamètre couvrir
il bosse tout ce qui fait juste pour le
plaisir on s'est fait un petit medley
des moments les plus drôles de la
cérémonie et forcément il ya encore du
diabète regardez françois si on pouvait
maintenant remettre le césar je vais le
faire si toi tu es payé wap ans
y'a pas l'enjeu c'est normal on te l'a
pas me gêner ça pour quoi
parce que voilà on sait bien que toute
façon tu vas dire le nom que tu veux
donc mais c'était il ya longtemps c'est
j'ai mûri tu sais j'ai manqué les nommés
dans cette catégorie meilleur acteur
dans un second rôle
jamel debbouze dans le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain
[Applaudissements]
on
merci infiniment sincèrement ces
antiquités je peux pas vous dire
c'est une boule d'énergie et de bonne
humeur kad merad
[Musique]
c'est basique
quand on voit quatre quand on voit gad
elmaleh de ça ça nous fait du bien une
autre cérémonie dont je voulais vous
parler
est ce que vous vous rappelez en 85e
cérémonie qui a disparu aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment les fameux 7 d'or les
prix d'intelligence était en gt en
partenariat avec télé 7 jours et petite
rétrospective des 7 d'or avec notamment
dans le magnéto regarder une des
séquences les plus fortes avec frédéric
mitterrand les 7 d'or c'était très très
attendu à l'époque et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la plein de chaînes pour
essayer de leur faire et personne n'y
arriverais benjamin caisse car les
caisses qui a renchéri j'en ai eu un 7
d'or ah oui c'est vrai pour paulo la wii
et ben oui je les vends babra bah oui
quoi et vraiment décidément excellent il
regarde et je supporte plus s'il vous
plaît laissez le forcené tranquille et
il a réussi ou pelé matthieu chalmé vous
avec le forcené
allez c'est parti le 7 d'or est
attribuée à champs elysées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
normalement quand on a un 7 d'or je
pensais pas l'avoir parce que
normalement quand on est à cette heure
on est dirait lendemain mais et se
trouve que là c'est arrivé la veille
je prends ce 7 d'or et puis je le mets
là où se trouve le service public
une jolie blonde des bluebell girls
selon rama sera sans doute tout à
l'heure devant les caméras de tf1
triomphante c'est à dire par terre du
bonheur et des bises celle de catherine
jacob et jean luc delarue merci ça fait
plaisir c'est juste pas d'oreillette
mais j'ai préparé des notes pour deux
secondes des bises et de l'émotion même
pour thierry ardisson qu'on croyait
blasé je remercie vraiment beaucoup
parce que je m'y attendais pas
franchement je pensais que pour la
dernière année vous leur est donné à
pivot quand même franchement ça fait du
bien de revoir tout ça est serré alors
pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui ça
pourrait pas exister
est-ce que malgré que j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui ça s'est su être
tellement de guerre de chaînes que vous
pourriez pas réunir tous les groupes
comme ça et avant il y avait une bien
meilleure ambiance et réclame c'est la
guerre c'est la guerre entre les goûts